[Applaudissements]
monsieur verdez pour ne pas nommer fait
une campagne citadine prétentieuse la
mienne c'est le retour de leurs rural la
terre mater bonjour madame
matthieu delormeau c'est quoi passer un
enfant en terme d'image c'est très bon
un enfant peut le prendre un peu comme
ça des amis comme le dit si bien harold
qui a envie d'avoir un avenir et bien
voté pour moi je suis son assurance son
assurance bonheur j'aime les enfants
thème d'avenir
merci coupé jean monsieur mais reconnu
ça m'arrive rarement mais c'est le
quotidien jill ce que vous venez de voir
où je comptais peut-être sur ton vote le
vote de l'avenir je sais pas j'aime bien
regarder vous voterez pour vous
absolument et moment c'est quoi s'ils
n'obtenaient pas ce que je peux compter
sur vos doigts plutôt que ce refus de
gilles verdez il devant je crois en mono
mais je sais rien dire votez de
l'armance et voter pour le bo n'oubliez
jamais a qu'un sur toi
[Applaudissements]